It is the United States of America's birthday, July 4th,
H F O D last year for July 4th.
I got completely underwater hammered. I was scuba diving, dude. I remember.
It. I remember you were bad. I remember, uh, Billy Berbee in there, uh,
singing the national Anthem.
Then he sang the Canadian national Anthem and it was funny. Um,
and I had a short throat, like I always do.
I had a sore throat and I had to get, uh, one of the guests at the barbecue.
Who's a nurse to look at my throat and call me and antibiotics. And I left.
Here's the thing about the 4th of July was with the squeak. There's no.
More American holiday than.
The 4th of July,
because all we do are staples of American culture.
First of all, we get the flag.
Out strong. I mean, all glories flying everywhere, because.
Make no mistake,
you do not forget that you were in the friendly confines of the United States of
America on July 4th.
You do not know.
You could even be somebody with dementia and you're going to go,
which country am I in? In? Oh yeah. America.
Cause there's reminders everywhere. It's just not for one second.
Are you going to think.
You're in Canada? No chance. Cause, and you know,
what's interesting about July 4th is it only became a federal holiday in 1941.
I did that. That was just the beginning.
Of world war two. It was beginning of world war II.
I mean the United States didn't come in. Oh yeah.
The United States had already come in. They'd come in in a,
for me to pill hopper. So yeah, I think, um.
So it's kind of like Juneteenth, hasn't been a holiday,
but it's going to be one at one point like 4th of July
became a holiday. Yeah. Like people.
Didn't even get off for 4th of July before 1941. It was always celebrated.
It was always celebrated, um, with festival, you know,
festivities and fireworks, all that stuff because I gotta be honest with you.
I mean, we live in New York city and we got a cutout mayor, mayor,
bill de Blasio. And it's like, I don't, I,
every day I've been hearing fireworks. Yeah. I mean, it's, it.
Sounded like 4th of July has been here for a month with the civil unrest going
on. But here's the deal.
The actual 4th of July is coming and here's a few rules that you need to know
about 4th of July one,
God have old glory flying got up to God.
Have Budweiser's on-call yeah.
You got to drink beer all day long to celebrate America. Number three,
God have hot dogs. Yep.
You gotta eat a combination of pig and sphincter in a tube all day
long because that's America. Number three.
Nobody who doesn't have an American passport is allowed at your barbecue.
For those county. Y'all did two number threes.
It's what it is because I'm a $3 bill. It's what it is because me and you,
if you put us together, what do we got? $6, $6.
Which is enough to buy hotdogs.
We form one foot and we are two half men,
two half.
Men make no mistake. Uh,
the show guy code and girl code is coming back tomorrow for one day episode
called quarantine code. And I'm sorry I was trying to do it. I don't want to do.
It. It's going to be real funny to see that show come back.
It's almost like it's almost like the reboot of Roseanne where
everyone just looks like their grandparents. Yeah.
I'm just like, yeah, I don't want to be doing the guy,
caught a girl coat to hide my. I'm 35 years old. I got a family.
I mean, it's too old. Why did we bring this thing back? Because I got to do it.
And I'm just so tired right now. And the thought of having to do it tomorrow is.
Me off. It's like when they sick,
when they brought back the same cash to Goodfellows for one more run in a
Scorsese movie, uh,
and they had to use CGI to make you guys look decent. And it's just.
What it is. And the truffle pig's getting 10%, unfortunately.
Cause he sent the email right before I can't them.
John Adams said that July 2nd,
he thought was the correct date to celebrate independence.
Cause that's when they really wrote the declaration of independence and talked
about it. But wasn't in Tala.
Uh, I don't give a about John Adams.
If I can't buy you at a six packs at the bodega. You're not my favorite Adams.
Yeah. I mean John Adams, he.
Used to turn down July 4th, um, uh,
events in protest because he thought now, why do you think it was on July 2nd?
Because on July 2nd is when they actually wrote the declaration of independence.
But July 4th is when they all signed it. Is that what it is?
Oh, July 2nd.
The continental Congress voted in favor of the declaration of independence.
But July 4th it wants to, why is it July 4th then? Does anybody know?
Because the great type of barbecue. Oh, because.
July 4th, the continental Congress formally adopted declaration of independence,
which had been written largely by Thomas Jefferson.
It's a slight bone and he's canceled. He's canceled.
And here's another piece of advice for you on the 4th of July.
If you're at a barbecue where you see a lot of white air force ones
and long white t-shirts make no mistake.
You're in a black barbecue. Yeah.
If you have the option for a side vegetable like asparagus making no
mistake, you're in a white barbecue. It's what.
It is. And let me tell you something.
If you're at a barbecue and they start playing the national
Anthem and everybody in that barbecue, including your disabled grandmother,
doesn't get down on one knee. You're a racist. You're.
A racist and a communist. You're a.
Communist. You better get granny down on one knee. I don't care.
She breaks her hip it's for the red, white and blue.
Yeah. It's what.
It's what it is. July 4th. Let's cancel.
It. Let's cancel.
Cancel July 4th. Cause I mean,
our people can't even celebrate July 4th because it's all racist white men that
made the holiday. So I'm celebrating Stalin's.
Birthday on July 14th. Kinsey's cancel, cancel at head sold.
It's cause we should just do a thing where we just read somewhat read somebody
and we just go let's cancel them. Let's cancel stuff. Let's cancel.
Cancel it. Let's camp. How do I cancel? I want to cancel myself.
Let's just cancel it.
Cancel John Adams canceled Nancy Reagan canceled,
canceled Alf. The TV show canceled. Yeah,
because it portrayed aliens weirdly canceled.
Why do you keep flexing your debts?
I've caught it throughout the whole episode because
why do you keep flexing your chest too much coffee? What are you doing?
Are you trying to grow your? Why are you so conscious of your?
I'm trying to straighten out my anteater tit,
because we've been sitting the whole time. About four times.
I see new flex in them. Why are you doing that? Why are you a strange bird?
I'm a strange bird. You're a $3 bell. It's.
What it is. Cause I mean, what can you do? I mean,
this it's socialism is taken off.